es gibt auf dieser welt unfassbar
liebenswürdige menschen es gibt gute
menschen es gibt ok menschen es gibt
schlechte menschen und es gibt solche
menschen denen man wünscht dass bei
ihnen auf lebenszeit die ärmel beim
händewaschen in diese letzte kategorie
des schlimmsten menschen auf der welt
zählen auch carens weil sie zum jetzigen
zeitpunkt noch nicht wissen was eine
carroll ist dürft ihr euch einerseits
glücklich schätzen andererseits helfe
ich euch und kläre ich sofort auf canons
sind meistens mittelalter also so fekter
von 30 bis 45 55 jahre alte frauen die
einfach ekelhaft sind wenn es wirklich
heißt das kannst du diese frauen leben
vollkommen unabhängig voneinander an
ganz unterschiedlichen orten auf der
welt aber sie verhalten sich genau
gleich und wie das werden jetzt sehen
das heutige video bin ich auf tik tok
unterwegs unter dem hashtag carron 6,4
milliarden aufrufe finden wir videos
über currents und wir fangen merkmalen
die meistens in englisch übersetzt für
euch also ist sie irgendwann im park und
die frau sagt hey internet weil sie
merkt dass sie gefilmt wird dieser
manier hat mit seinem dobermann gerade
mich und mein tiger angegriffen und der
kamera so ergeht nicht mal auf die rede
dass kein dobermanns fangen wir mal da
an wird es dort gespürt dass es ist
nicht echt leute es ist echt glaubt es
mir diese frauen falls ihr ihn in ihrem
leben uns begegnet seid geschätzt euch
glücklich aber es gibt diese carens
leute und genauso sind die drauf
kleinere hat mir das kann eben gesehen
sie tut an den punkt einfach so als
hätte der hund zugebissen
dabei ist der hund nicht mal in der nähe
wie kann man so sein ding
wie kann man so sein bitte bitte sagt es
mir leute schieben sich diese menschen
nicht egal weiter ok nächste szene
mittendrin wieder eine carron diesmal
also sich komplett anders aus dass man
sich schwarze haare bist ein kleiner
biss untersetzer und dass irgendein
grund hängt hat sich diese kämen auf das
auto von jemandem vorne draufgehen und
weigert sich zu bewegen
sie sagte youtube mio was hast du lust
traum ich freue mich über den haufen und
also runter vom auto wirklich nicht was
sind das für menschen mit gesagt ist mir
leute sie hängt es ist ein komplett
freier parkplatz nicht kennen die
vorgeschichte nicht aller
wahrscheinlichkeit macht das hier beim
unrecht weil können sind immer im
unrecht wie sind die in dieser situation
reingekommen und noch mehr fragt man
sich wie können diese menschen diese
carens diese ausgeburten der hölle ich
muss das wirklich so sagen das habe ich
wirklich sehr wie können die in einer
gesellschaft überleben legt sich auf das
auto eines fremden mannes und ist
zutiefst schockiert als er sie anruft
mehr sage ich dazu nicht
das ist wirklich zu viel gab es für
menschen
da steht sie habe ich eigentlich erst
friede sie sagt so okay jetzt habe ich
dich bekommt sei nicht raus du denkst du
hast mich erwischt sagt sie zu ihm
so weiß man sich wieso der quad-fahrer
sie erwischen sollte aber okay das ist
ein grundstück und sie so ich kann
machen was auch immer ich will
ich war wirklich die fassung bei diesen
videos sie hat einfach fest irgendwann
mal aufgefallen dass sie einfach einen
regenschirm als mütze hat sie hatte ich
so ein regenschirm kappe bezwingt sie
angesagt so ja du infiziert meine lungen
mit den dämpfen mit den abgasen vom quad
hängen geblieben
das ist das gejammer dass das ist
wirklich zu hat
nein wieso gibt es solche menschen leute
wie so viele wir vielen wirklich die
worte wenn ich sowas hier meine erste
reaktion ist ich will hier einfach ab
wenn ja an der gurgel packen wirklich
weil ich mir nicht anders zu helfen weil
es sehen ihres wie sie da wegrennt wir
wirklich wie in einem schlechten
computer spielt wie ein npc ein vom
computergesteuerter charaktere so läuft
sie weg
[Musik]
er leitet das jetzt auch gute partie
siegten geschaut
also wie gesagt was mein auto berührt
wie kann sowas machen
ich hab dich berührt und die frau so
weißt du wie viel das kostet und die mit
dem fahrrad da ist nicht wahrscheinlich
hat sich wirklich aus so einfach nicht
berührt und die kennedy auf der rechten
seite
sie sieht aber auch wieder ausfindig
erkennt dass den typ mittlerweile dreht
jetzt vollkommen wieder ich will und sie
sagen was sie wollen wie auch die kern
gerade eben leute wie geht das diese
leute kennen einander nicht aber die
reden alle gleich genauso in deutschland
mit sicherheit sie wollen sie wollen
immer irgendwas sie wollen irgendwie
nahm dann drohen sie die polizei
anzurufen obwohl sie selbst im unrecht
sind leute das hier ist das kern
einmaleins was ihr euch gerade gebe
das kann doch nicht wahr sein wie wie
können solche leute existieren die frage
wenn ich jetzt jedes mal stellen bis ich
eine antwort darauf habe wie kann es
sein dass unsere gesellschaft solche
leute unter sich hat so weil du dich
oder das wird dass es auch geld durch
fest was sehen wir hier leute eine wo
ein wunderschönes setting die natur im
hintergrund ist wirklich bezaubernd wir
sehen eine herren mit einem schönen
schäfer und der langlaufen der der arme
hund erst zu dieser frau aushalten muss
und natürlich leute wenn wir genau
hinschauen erkennen wir die kern hat ihr
handy schon draußen und filmt weil das
ist eine der haupt tätigkeiten von
cairns leute stehen also dass du ja du
bist wirklich bezaubernd kennen du bist
eine ganz tolle frau und sie sagt you
are going sie fängt schon so an jura
gros der satz you are going to jail den
wollte sie wahrscheinlich gerade sagen
also du gehst ins gefängnis sie soll
mass bilder von garten über diesen
ganzen kerl sie die immer diese diese
passive aggression meist ist es nicht so
passiert aber die können auch nicht so
richtig sauer sein bisschen wenn ich
richtig sauer bin also was das passiert
in der hand weisen ii aber dann will ich
ja jemand eine reinhauen so wie auch
immer carens können das nicht
bei denen ist höchstes aggressions und
wut niveau mit dem handy jemand zu
filmen und dann so wie sie jetzt gerade
das handy gegen das andere zu stoßen
leute das ist endstufe und das ist auch
so geil weil die innerlich kocht handy
auf dem letzten auf der letzten rille
aber die können dann irgendwie sie
müssen sich nicht zu helfen oder dass
sie und das habe ich auch schon mal
gesehen das ist auch wählt das ist auch
in einem handyladen oder so
ok also es ist ein handygeschäft ich
glaube es ist ein reisen store dass er
so ein netzanbieter sowie telekom oder
vodafone drüber in den usa und so wie
ich das verstanden aber wie er das schon
mal gesehen wurde dieser frau einfach
gesagt ja wir können ihn mit ihrem
anliegen in diesem laden hier nicht
weiterhelfen
sie müssen in den anderen laden von
unserer marke gehen der 300 meter weiter
weg ist und diese kevin hat nicht so
bock ihr seid einfach hinten ticker
schon mal vorher arbeit in seinem handy
laden wir sie sagt der frau einfach nur
so
die hat tut mir leid für den speziellen
bereich den sie jetzt gerade beauftragen
wollen mit ihrem handy sind wir nicht
zuständig dafür ist es ist einfach nur
die andere filialen nur 200 meter weiter
weg sie lässt einfach so satan
persönlichere ausleger wie können diese
menschen überleben
ich muss es wissen sollte ich muss das
wissen aber leute die aufnahme geht
schon viel zu lange ich ich könnte das
noch stundenlang machen wirklich
stundenlang lass mich in den kommentaren
wissen was eure persönlichen erfahrungen
mit carols sind dann ob er einen zweiten
teil davon wollte zeigen dass man am
liveticker hat vorgeschlagen dass wieder
auf die oben geht er manchmal bringen
macht's gut
von bernd kehren